[Music]
hello everyone this is Grand Master Josh
Patel and today I'm grieving
I'm doing the games of skill by heart
lecture so last week I did a game
between a probably a lesser-known game
between Greg surfer and Siwon is
Nikolaidis and so that one I say most of
you probably haven't hadn't seen but
again one of my favorite games this game
I'd say is definitely more famous it's
played between two elite players of the
time so this was played in 1991 it was
in their candidates match they had
actually tied the match it was between
vasily even shook and archer Yasuko they
had their match tied at 4-4 and this
game Yusupov as black won an amazing
fashion and it kind of you know
jump-started him to winning this match
against even Chuck who was the heavy
favorite I'd say maybe not the heavy
favorite but definitely going into the
match was the favorite and this game
especially for a rapid game was a really
incredible idea and it's kind of what
happens when you have two extremely
creative players playing against each
other even true can you super for both
creative they both come up with really
interesting ideas and when two of them
play you can get very interesting chests
um but this particular game I'd say was
definitely one of the nicest games I've
seen and again a little bit more likely
you guys have seen this game before it's
included in several attacking books I'm
sure but it's still a really beautiful
game and it's one of those where I don't
like computers in this game because they
definitely ruin it there were a lots of
mistakes made but you have to keep in
mind this was a 1991 this is a rapid
match and the position was immensely
complicated and there are positions
where even computers it takes them a
little while so a game like this you
have to turn off your engine and try to
figure things out on your own
we're going to make mistakes we're not
going to see everything perfectly it's
completely impossible but at the same
time we can still enjoy the chest and
enjoy the beautiful idea let's get
started I'm not going to spend too much
time the opening because it's so complex
and the the game later got so
interesting but it was in English
slightly weird move order I would say
but you get kind of a typical position
it's all it's more like a 97 Kings
Indian at this point even trip decides
not to go free for but this is also a
fairly well known idea again fairly
normal development for both sides even
trip plays a fairly aggressive move in
Bishop a3 immediately trying to make
this Queen feel uncomfortable with life
so again taking on d4 I'd say is maybe
more typical in playing 95 I don't want
to say more typical but maybe safer but
you slip off decides that he wants to go
for a more double-edged position which
is more true to his style and even cook
never shied away from double-edged
positions either so I'm sure both were
fairly happy with this turn of event
black plate efore so again we're going
to go for a situation where black will
be trying to play attacking on the Kings
side and white will be attacking on the
Queen side and yes you can attack what
there's no King it just doesn't end in
checkmate and ends and taking your
opponent's pieces so Knight g5 was
played so this pawn is now a weakness d5
is ill-advised do the hanging Queen so
III is the move so I have my first
question to my audience which is grown
substantially since my last lecture ah
which move would you play here now
obviously taking the pawn Queen takes
pawn is bad for a billion reasons not
least of which is that it's a fork of
the king and Knight but also just
opening the King in is just generally
undesirable so allowing pawn takes pawn
is almost always almost certainly bad so
you have to candidate moves here those
be
f3 and f4 and I would say that one of
these moves I definitely like more than
the other and it was not the move that
was played so I'm curious which of these
moves you guys would play because again
it's not a completely obvious decision
but I think that clearly one of the
moves I prefer over the so we have one
vote let's take a vote how many want f3
just from the first impression without
calculating too many variations ah
a lot of people have how many like f4 a
tiger yeah I don't think I use quite the
same expressive language as Sarah
Wanda's so but again I like this game so
much that I could I could see that I
could see someone else go over this game
I could go over it and then we'll
immediately watch someone else go over
it I like this game so much but it's
also so complex that probably Yasser
mentioned many things I didn't mention
and probably I'll mention some things he
didn't mention and very likely he
mentioned them in a much slower voice so
so can't resist I had to do it so
between f3 and f4 why do you let me put
it this way so you've seen in the game
so you kind of cheated that's okay I
don't I don't I don't judge why do you
guys like f3 f2 regards e4 exactly and I
think this is very important because if
you are able to access the e4 square for
example after f3 94 is a big deal
because d6 is a weakness right so it
looks weird because you're blocking your
Bishop but supporting this efore this 94
move I think is really important so for
example if Knight f8 I'd say both
neither Knight to e4 is possible
although it's not even necessarily the
necessary to play it immediately but for
example of 94 fish about five queen can
drop back
and I say in this position okay white
pawn structure is a little weird to put
it mildly but with E 5 coming this being
week the two bishops looking kind of
nice I probably prefer white in most of
these positions yes that's true but I
would say that Knight g4 f2 is mainly a
problem because then I can't land here
so easily or plant staff but that's very
true however having seen the game
hindsight 20/20 it's easier to draw
these conclusions but it's important not
to do that you have to try to keep the
position kind of like from their
perspective during the game I'm pretty
sure even chip did not realize he was
about to be brutally checkmated or or
something along these lines so you have
to look at it from the point of view
there are they're still right out of the
opening they don't know what's going to
happen so you know even if you kind of
have an idea of how the games are going
to transpire try to look at it from
their shoes exactly how they're going to
play
I like f3 supporting 94 he played at 4
and here I was going to ask what you
soup well played but I'm pretty sure you
guys know oh it's not nice for you that
was that anyway he's getting out of the
way so this pawn can be defended it's
necessary but also Bishop f5 is coming
and this is again another reason I don't
like what he did because if you get in
Bishop a5 this e4 square is better
covered from blacks perspective where
did you play f3 it supports it a little
bit more so even sure continues to
attack again these moves you could spend
a long time on these moves as well but
this game is so complicated I want to
save most of the analysis from later
Bishop f5 was played fairly natural
Queen goes to b3 h6 Knight goes back to
f3 and now Knight g4 comes so black is
basically using this pond of a spearhead
start the attack the knight can land on
f2 the pawn g5 is going to come and in
fact g5 could have happened here
immediately as well and this is another
very interesting way to play
so for example just to give you an idea
what would happen if white tries to grab
this tunnel where is this noise coming
from and again I don't have this line
entered so we're going to explore as if
we didn't know what's going to happen
because we don't so now if I play here
so again this v6 problem can sometimes
come into play but because the bishop's
momentarily blunted I think it's not
going to be so easy so you might have a
move like net f2 and Alfred and again I
would say that black has lots of counter
plays so again maybe white shouldn't be
grabbing this pawn maybe white should
find another move here b5 is certainly a
possibility just trying to keep at it
and if g4 Knight h4 you haven't achieved
too much but I think that this g5 move
was maybe worth considering as well
black opted for Knight g4 even choke
true to form plays b5 and black plays g5
so it's already entering territory where
I said I'd say white has to be very
careful and very precise and for a while
at least even shook at least in my
opinion plays extremely well considering
you're facing such an attack it's very
easy to panic when you face an attack
because you know no one likes being
attacked but the fact is that sometimes
rather than playing purely defensive
moves you have to come up with ideas for
counter play basically moves that make
counter threats move the do stuff on the
other side of the board it's necessary
when you're defending innocent attack
but the key is you cannot be slow slow
play is almost always punished when
you're getting attacked
so what move would you guys consider for
white here but yeah basically if you if
you take this pawn then you lose this
grip on the square for sure not to
mention that all of a sudden then you
have to watch out for a knight f2 and
everything kind of flying at you
so what 95 does he took on c6 first by
the way because the thing is you want to
be attacking a weak
when you play 95 right so he threw this
move in before playing and this is kind
of crucial because you want to be able
to play Knight takes c6 right sometimes
for example if you play 95 too early
there's a possibility that say if the
Queen moves you don't have time to play
Knight takes c6 and I might have time to
grab your knife just as an example so
usually you want to open up lines first
and then play 95 and again I really like
this move because otherwise I mean what
are you going to do like you can't
really break through here that easily if
you play d5 I play c5f c5 I of d5 you
can't try to open up the Queen side and
again if y can't get Queens like counter
play you're just going to die because
this attacks can eventually crush
through so 95 opens up the bishop
threatened design take c6 and really the
game takes an interesting turn
so black captures on f4 again you can't
really defend this pawn and sometimes if
you try to defend indivisible things you
end up kind of just wasting time so he's
going to pitch this pawn but he needs to
keep his attack going also takes here
has another advantage apart from just
taking upon what have you done that's
good for you well not yet there's still
quite a few things on this file yes the
Queen now has a square if the night
lands on c6 and the Queen has to go to
some square like f6 and you wanted a
Knight d5 you're probably in bad shape
right and your queen doesn't want to
move away and not be able to access the
King side this is a common pattern
actually in a Kings Indian that you
choose your attacking moves at the right
moment because you need your Queen to
have a square over here in order to keep
attacking
so pawn takes pawn yes you're a
capturing a pawn but you're doing it at
a very specific point in order to give
your Queen this square so white captures
on c6 looks kind of crazy but at the
same time you need a way to get counter
play you need you need kind of play
right now so if you don't start taking
these pawns you're not going to have any
chance for example taking this pawn
would be near suicide any reasons why
yeah now maybe you could take the night
but even if you just simply recapture I
think with Queen coming in and Bishop
coming in it's just going to be really
bad
keep in mind you only have one defender
over here now so this move I think is
better Queen comes out to g5 hmm maybe
but you're also keep in mind first of
all do you want to take one of these
rooks probably not right because your
bishop is one of your only defenders if
you this is one of the things I've
noticed when attacking if your opponent
has one defender that counts that's so
much better than zero that seems obvious
but when you have one defender it's
amazing sometimes just having a bishop
on g2 you can fend it off really crazy
attack and you'll actually see that this
game he has the one defender and it
makes blacks attacks so much harder but
if you have zero defenders a blown King
gets checkmated super fast so giving up
this one defender I'd say is normally a
bad idea so for example after Bishop
takes c6 let's say I even just take this
pawn if you want to take one first of
all I don't recommend taking one of
these rooks but also keep in mind that
now this nice loser so here I might even
be able to just take this Knight and
play simple chess
something like this and you can feel
free you can feel free to take one of
these rooks but after I recapture your
King has zero defenders I do not believe
it'll last very long so you have to be
very careful about this Knight takes c6
I think is very important because it
leaves this Bishop here and also it's a
temple something else that's important
Queen here even should takes on d6 this
move looks super greedy but it also
serves another purpose you're not just
taking a pawn what are you doing exactly
the bishop now participates in defense
so what do you play here if your book
so in the game 96 was played which i
think is a very logical move because
first of all you're defending this pawn
defending attack pieces is usually a
good idea but apart from that you're
bringing another piece to the party
maybe Bishop f8 in some situations we'll
try to get rid of this Bishop and also
you're keeping your options open
sometimes you might want to take but
other times maybe you'll take on h2
maybe you'll play queen h5 and 96 keep
these options open for you that's
something I was going to mention
possibly we'll get to that in a moment
but I just wanted to mention that when
you're attacking when at some point you
have to commit to something and then
usually there's a long line and either
you checkmate or you lose brutally or
you perpetual check something like this
but before you go for the throat before
you try to go for the winning line often
you have you want to keep your options
open the reason for this is that if you
can make if you have a few different
ways you're going to attack your
opponent they don't know how to set up
their defense they don't know how to
kind of keep you at bay whereas if you
commit to exactly one plan of attack
right away oftentimes they're able to
defend against them more easily because
they know what your next moves are going
to be when you play ninety six white
still isn't sure if you're going to take
here or play Queen h5 right so in the in
that sense I like this move but a
position like this of course is always
very concrete and it requires a precise
calculation and thinking because you
can't logic a position like it's just
too much too much craziness happening so
Knight take stage two was certainly a
possibility and now there are lots of
moves but just to give you an example of
how some of these lines can go King
takes h2 I think would be a very bad
idea
because you take King back here this
would be even pinning yourself will be
even worse because of this and here what
would you do
Bishop h3 I don't like as much again I
prefer getting the night in the reason
why if Bishop age three I have a couple
options first of all I'm not obligated
to take your vision
I can maybe move away or even put it on
f3 and it's not clear this helps you but
I also might consider a move like this I
don't know this is a little bit lamb
little lesser of because maybe you'll
play Queen h4 and now I'd at least be
nervous let's put it that way but at the
same time the rooks lined up with the
King so you might find actually giving
checkmate not all that easy but ok I
have a kind of a problem here because
you're threatening too much yeah
probably I should just move my vision
say Bishop Webster but I like 19:6
because then you're going to bring
another piece into the attack the arrow
this means you have an attack you ever
see this in chess space the arrow means
you have an attack but the key here is
that again if you have a choice between
like you know just attacking with two
pieces and bringing another piece in
almost always you want another piece to
come in trying to give checkmate with
just two pieces is one of the ways
people fail to checkmate and in any case
this would have been an interesting
option but white probably would take on
f4 which to me is a more logical move
why would you take this and allow Queen
takes g3 but even this is unclear you
play Queen h5 then i comes to d5 and the
position is just crazy I'm threatening
to take on e3 I'm threatening 97 check
but at the same time if I bring my
knight back I'm threatening Queen h2
maybe there's no checkmate immediately
but it's definitely threatening and
again this is just another way you could
have gotten insanity but not to worry
insanity fans we end up there anyway and
a g6 was played Knight d5 so again
you're thinking at first like why is
white just ignoring all these threats
well in order to get these in order to
defend against this onslaught you need
pieces so 95 you're not just attacking a
pawn you're bringing pieces into the
disattached and defense
maybe you'll play 97 check maybe you'll
play 19 step 4 but having pieces that
are multi-dimensional is
important the problem right has that the
two rooks and the Queen are not
participating in the defense and that
can definitely hinder thing
so here black played queen h5 and once
again nice take stage two was maybe an
option to consider
so as I've mentioned lots of
possibilities so and this is this is
something to give you an idea of how
complex this is Yusupov who by the way
is very workman like in how he looks at
chests annotated this game and in his
annotations because they were done
probably in the 90s I'd imagine soon
after this game was played he obviously
didn't have the use of a computer they
weren't computers back then never mind
strong ones so he had to analyze all
this on his own so a lot of his his
conclusions were actually not correct
but when you have a computer it makes it
look very easy but you have to realize
to analyze the position like this
without one it's very difficult but
let's give it a shot so let's say King
take page two how can black attack here
Queens e39 h4 might be possible and
again keep in mind that a lot of these
lines is more than one ways there's not
always just one way to skin a cat as
they say but let's see it's 9 h4 how
would you defend against Knight takes
pawn
I might have also had 97 check I should
mention I don't know if throwing that in
makes sense but I'm going to go with the
simpler move simpler in quotes this
would be 4 so your threat is to take on
g2 as well as maybe nothing else
so what else what if I just capture your
Bishop here rub Tiggs
and then rook do you want I don't know
if you're going to give checkmate here
I'm getting pieces into the defense your
knight and queen are not coordinating
very well I must say and I have moves
like Queen d7 hitting the rook and
threatening 97 and the Queen has
discoveries galore here for example
after here I might just have a much
simpler move maybe even Knight h5 is
just good but I move like Queen d7 can
be actually kind of nasty
because now I'm threatening your rook
I'm 1387 you see how your attack kind of
grinds to a halt after a couple
imprecise moves and again it's not
really a criticism to play this position
is really tough but Queen h4 check and
Queen up to check is rather important so
here you could take a draw by the way I
feel like I should point this out
because you know if you already have a
draw on hand that certainly makes your
life easier but I think you can just
take this pawn and now despite the fact
you're still down material look at these
guys those pawns are going to be nasty
if they start rolling up the board I
think that it's just going to be over so
I can take this pawn for example so now
you take and then you have Bishop C to
winning a rook so this would be an
example of a line where white fails to
impress so Knight takes f4 is another
possibility and these are the two moves
given by you super of incidentally 96 f4
and King Baker used to it turns out
neither is best but just to give you an
example Knight take that for what would
you guys do
well that's kind of sad well so again um
okay so this kind of thinking I don't
like you're trying to attack right do
you think you have time for moves like
med FA tonight eh eh hmm okay but but I
would say that almost for sure you don't
have time for something like that this
attack is very time you know it's very
time dependent right right if you spend
the move retreating that's not only a
piece you're bringing away from being a
potential attacker but it's also time
you're spending a move so I would say
that move if you're trying to attack
moves like meta fate and especially I
mean that h8 I don't know what to say to
this one this one almost never put your
Knights in the corner ever there
actually was a got top game in the last
year yeah jabong oh I even gave a
lecture on this game where you put a
knight on h8 but I'm like guys never do
this he only did it actually because
there was only way to not lose a piece
but do not put Knights in the corner
almost ever just not a good idea
maybe if f7 is the biggest weakness of
all time you can put your knight here
but yeah so again don't look for moves
that move backwards until you've
consider ones that move forwards Queen
g3 8 should certainly be considered 96
f4 is also possible but takes here so if
I take on g6 and this is the thing I
think that Yusupov was constraint
thinking purely in positional terms he's
like oh he takes bishop but after Queen
takes bishop I think it's not so clear
however taking this Knight is actually
just very strong because now I don't
have much I can do for example let's say
Bishop takes h2 you have a very simple
move and this guy is just a goner and if
you try 97 check for example I can just
take it because again you're getting
attacked way too fast I also note how it
does not really hang because the pin so
really you're actually already out of
options and if King takes Knight I can
simply take this Bishop with check and
that position is a lot clearer but again
when you have this many pieces hanging
it's tough to decide which one
but I would say look for the most
straightforward way first and that's
usually a good thing to do but Queen
takes three three is a key move because
the fact that you're pinning the bishop
is nice but also it's just you have way
too many pieces around the King so I
think Bishop takes up four is actually a
better move and now the lines get super
super cray Queen h5 is an interesting
move but I don't even want to get into
this one it it was too messy I mean I'm
looking at this position I'm trying to
figure things out I'm turning on the
computer and it's spitting out a bunch
of nonsense I just a suffice it to say
Queen h5 is an interesting move but to
me the human choice is just taking this
bishop because this bishop is defending
this pawn right you want to take away
your opponent's key defenders almost
always so pawn takes Queen h4 so to me
this look really strong but it's amazing
how many defense of resources White has
and I take thee three is definitely a
logical move you go back to g4 takes on
g4 Bishop takes and again my impression
was that this position was actually just
unclear White should go back blocking
the rook but okay you can maybe take on
e2 at some point
play route create flax Kings open why
does a lot of palms but at the same time
because this King so open because this
is a weakness which probably is going to
get taken soon I'd say that it's at
least an unclear position so this was
actually maybe objectively better even
than what he played but what he played
was so interesting that in a lot of ways
is kind of nice he didn't play this he
played queen h5 which is a very direct
move obviously he wants to put his queen
on h2 and scare white a little bit so
white plays h4 can't really allow it and
again we come to a situation where it's
hard to judge objectively whether his
move is absolutely correct or anything
like that but it's such a difficult
position to play that and remember this
is a rapid game this is a game 60 in all
likelihood they had under 20 minutes
here imagine having to play this
position with full time you really have
to
I on your instincts a lot you have to be
calculating like crazy but a lot of it
you have to rely on attacking instincts
his instinct told him to take on h4 I
don't think we should argue with him
he a denied f2 is a move that was really
interesting
he had F takes G 3 but to me this is
kind of lame right and believe it or not
this is actually just a perp then that
goes back and forth that would be a it
would be terrible if the game ended that
way right maybe maybe a subject would be
better than what he did but they'll be
awful so he ticks we're going to stick
to tick so white actually does not is
not obligated to take this knight
immediately and in my opinion shouldn't
throwing in this check is actually very
annoying so King h7 it's almost always
that this square is bad because it just
runs into too much stuff for example
after it takes takes takes this is just
really bad because the King like you can
play Queen c2 in a lot of positions
exposing the King and it's just not very
good and you'll see why this is the
worst version so almost always sorry you
have to put your King on hh9 takes up 4
Knight f3 check because obviously but
also I mean you need to move right if
you go here I can probably even just
take your knife so Knight f3 check pawn
takes Queen check and now rook takes you
seven because the main move if you play
Queen takes g3 I have this one and if
one of the reasons why against King age
7 you actually just take the knight by
the way
so instead rook takes you seven pawn
takes g4 and again yes there are a lot
of possibilities here but taking the
rook would make no sense because when I
take on g3 right and you're again going
to get checkmated probably so you take
this Knight to eliminate some pieces e
to check and this is actually one of the
key things and this is where the
computer is so strong because it just
sees whether there's checkmates or not
after takes
you can just play queen up three
cold-blooded rooks attacked rooks
defended defending against mates so you
take here so now to make sure every
piece is hanging and believe it or not
there's no clear checkmate you can do
this but it's actually unclear whether
you have anything here and in fact again
from a human perspective I would say
that this would be kind of annoying to
play for white just cause you're Kings
wide open and I'd say a lot of games
would end in perpetual or something like
that computer actually likes full white
here I'm guessing just because this pawn
could start rolling eventually but again
human perspective this is kind of
ridiculous Knight f4 instead of
ninety-seven here I think if you do this
first let me see a moment so what if I
check now takes check and then what if I
play Queen takes pawn and say ha no
discovery cy 97 check was so important
because now this Knight can't move with
temple which means this checkmate will
be very painful
you can play Queen B 2 but now I can
distract you with this move I also may
be head Knight age to check but I like
this one better so you have to cover the
square you have to take with the Queen
and then I probably will just capture
but anyway so you can see how many
pitfalls there are in a position like
this in any case white took immediately
and he took this move was actually quite
interesting with the idea that after
check King h8 cuite to h4 there's your
back and probably black has nothing
better than a draw here
I know that's why I didn't play it he's
like ah forget that and here white has a
choice between which night do I check on
e7 whip baby nice try that's true but
there are different ways to think about
this
so both nights are defended so if work
takes you seven to the next move it
doesn't matter which night you're
absolutely correct but you can assume
rook takes you sevens probably not
coming right so then how do you decide
the difference between Knight d7 and
Knight C so that's that's a big part but
I may I try to simplify this question do
you like this night better or this night
better which night is more useful yd v
ya that's simple closer to the King said
it hits this pawn hits this pawn now
even shook is not a weak player even
with no time the dude sees amazing stuff
so I'm sure he had a concrete reason why
concrete I mean he calculated tons of
lines and saw a reason why the knight
de7 check was better but in this case it
was just better to be like look this
Knight is actually helping me defend
this Knight can actually help me do
stuff I should move the knight unseat to
be someone so Bishop takes f4 is another
move we're not even going to mess with
that one but Knights the e7 check would
was very possible as we know the King
should almost always good h8 here it's
just to open 96 f5 and again the
position is still kind of nuts after
check there's this move so here's the
deal
in this position white has black has
absolutely nothing with this Knight here
there's no Queen here there's no nothing
there's only one way black can generate
a threat now for those of you who've
seen this game you know how so I want
you to maybe not answer this one
but for those of you who have not seen
this game how can black generate a
threat here you need another piece
that's clear but before we get into why
Bishop e5 is such a stunning move and
then eventually why maybe it doesn't
quite work as they thought it did in the
annotations what how can black generate
a threat here there's only one way to do
it again the knight and queen are not
enough to checkmate by themselves it
can't move it love to move to g3 right
right but I can't because then I don't
have five such a monster it also doesn't
hurt that it's an extra night but but
here's the question what will your
threat be
well I didn't mean to do that okay but
how so if you get your rook into the
game what threat can you create that's
my question
key to my name that's true but this is
actually truly the most amazing part of
this game it was the mate threat that
was generated was really cool-looking so
let me just show you after Bishop e5 so
this move looks nonsensical like
especially if you don't see the idea
it's completely ridiculous very nice so
for those of you looking for this
pattern so Bishop takes me five is
actually what's given in the notes but
now you sack and by the way the reason
you play Bishop e5 is just to prevent a
capture on f4 because capture on f4
ruins your attack right so Bishop e5 is
interference and the idea is that a
bishop takes you sacrifice another
exchange and play here however the
threat of Queen h1 check is monstrous
and very difficult to get rid of to
prepare it like how do you stop queen h1
check it's really difficult so the funny
thing is so here here's the deal in this
position in the notes it's basically
given as yeah you can take on e3 and
lose you can do this and lose there's
actually a defense to Queen h1 check
here and I'd like you guys to find it
it's nuts though you have to use your
creative juices here if Knight g3 I
think that after Queen takes g3 you can
probably resign
and if Knight takes eat
I just capture Queen f4 check take here
and you're going to end up losing for
example yeah Queen here is going to be
mate and if you go to F if you go to f2
then I check here and after here Knight
take D one is actually double checkmate
although I should point out you don't
get two points for that you just get one
point for the further check yes it is
but you don't take a rook so it's not as
good that's okay
that does make it easier to spot because
it's really hard to spot it but
basically what our moves that block this
file imagine trying to play this move in
a chess game but you guys don't see how
it works yet right because okay King
cakes it's kind of obvious because
you're blocking the file right so for
example if King takes g7 you play Knight
f6 if f3 you take and this is where
things get really nuts
takes and you just run there are some
positions by the way you can actually
play King EE one here and give up the
world because you're up so much and this
is the thing when you're up so much
material as even took this game you can
actually the advantage of doing this
when you're defending now you think that
you can't be too greedy sometimes if you
take a lot of material and get
checkmated you don't get extra points
however what extra material lets you do
is if you have to pitch a rook and a
bishop everything to get out of
checkmate sometimes you can if you're up
a rook and five bishops for example and
you have to go for rock and for bishops
to prevent checkmate you can do it and
you'll still be up that extra bishop so
you can basically pitch everything and
apparently this is a draw
don't take my word for it
but you know and there's no way to
checkmate this king I couldn't believe
it
I tried everything the computer was just
like ha ha ha ha ha
moving the King around in circles and
there's just nothing to do I tried this
but unfortunately the King even hides on
v1 and it's a perpetual check by the way
it's important you don't mess it up
though if you play here now there's no
more perpetual but if when you go to g6
exactly so the Queen has to go back you
go back ha ha ha ha
good cetera quiet quite a line huh yeah
however rook takes would have made more
sense to me oops yeah so yeah rook here
you can often sack but if here
queen bee one pretty sick huh it's
pretty messed up by the way
long-distance Queen moves very difficult
to see for some reason so something you
have to keep in mind when you're looking
at games Queen h4 was another
possibility and then takes but yeah
Queen h4 you play King g1 that was the
one thing that might be possible but
it's more that because queens are so
scary looking when they're close I think
that one that you don't realize they can
move real far again I don't know why
this is but it's just one of those
geometric things so yeah rook g6 you can
just go here because notice how there's
no more checkmate because your rook
spins sorry you can and then I take it
and go here and then your fun is over
because I'm going to take I attend your
fun I really do but in any case Knight
g7 quite a move huh but imagine having
to find this with like two minutes even
shook by the way one of the few people
who might find that move but
unfortunately D takes e5 couldn't really
crack so at first you're like ah rook g8
Queen h2 is coming I'm in business go me
but white can actually defend against
this somehow miraculously
how to do so you have to take no other
move so there are two possibilities if F
takes again keep in mind what's the
threat so I'll just take it you won't be
able to defend for long 93 then I
probably have Queen a 4 again and taking
everything with check and then laughing
maybe not laughing but taking everything
oh so now if you Gloria if you try to be
like oh I got this checkmate I got this
checkmate unfortunately and now now now
you're down a little too much mature and
you just don't have anything now so
sorry this is f7 yeah what's that okay
but it doesn't really matter the whole
point is that as long as you don't get
checkmated here the game is over because
White's just up way too much material
taking an f7 is maybe a move that's
coming next but as long as there's no
checkmate black just loses because
blacks I mean look at it
white white as an extra Knight Bishop
Knight and Bishop right it's way too
much so Knight takes at first I thought
this might be winning but then I
realized what has this move defending
the bishop long-range long-range Queen
always the killer and there's just
nothing so this would have spoiled the
whole attack
but white plays Knight d7 check and you
think well how big a difference can it
really make but the fact that you don't
have this sac is actually very annoying
so check and here because that four is
not attacked another problem you're not
required to be like yeah there should be
five party you know you don't have to
give away all your pieces basically and
here he found this move rookie six which
again is part of his beautiful idea of
rook g6 but Bishop f6 would have been
very strong but here's the question what
exactly is the purpose of Bishop f6 rook
g8 is maybe one idea but it's very
primitive looking right but bishop if
the bishop lens one f2 you're gonna have
a real hard time stopping me think of it
like a bughouse game if you could drop a
bishop on f2 mates coming right or a
pawn up to but that's a little less
realistic in chess Bishop on a pseudo is
actually quite possible so Bishop h4 to
f2 is coming so for example if c5
actually I if white just plays like a c5
s kind of like a just improving move I'm
just using it as an example now rook g8
is the killer with Queen h1 as the idea
BAM such a beautiful checkmate right I
just lied just like looking at it to be
perfectly honest let's settle down
oh yes it's a really pretty checkmate
right but let's say they play rope d3 so
now if you try rook g8 I can sack and
again keep in mind I'm down I'm up lots
of material so I can afford the sack and
again this pin is coming back to bite
you so [ __ ] of h4 I have to sack anyway
and you don't care efore only move I
have to stop Queen g1 mate right
and it looks pretty killer again white
can maybe fight on but good luck trying
to defend this position especially with
no time
so Bishop f6 would have been really
strong but he played rookie six again he
liked this route g6 idea and white
played queen b7 which looks like a
perfectly normal move but it turns out
to lose kind of spectacularly after
Knight c e7 which is a better move there
are lots of different options Bishop f6
now is too slow because of cui b7 again
and note how you're not only threatening
to bring the Queen back but Queen takes
rook is a mate threat it's not just a
rook threat which is important when your
opponent is trying to give you checkmate
sometimes taking even a roof doesn't
matter but if you can then give
checkmate that does matter sounds basic
but hmm rook takes e7 sorry so Luke
takes d6 doesn't work because you simply
take it and now by the way Knight takes
f7 and Queen c2 is in a threat again so
giving your opponent a main threat is a
bad idea is what this comes down to
so rook takes you sevens a better move
and now there are two ways to capture
the rook as I'm sure you see so if this
ship takes it allows f3 but and this is
where his analysis was bad he only gave
takes and you take a bunch of stuff
maybe you say in the game right however
believe it or not you're up so much
material you can give away the world and
somehow wipe doing well here because you
parry all the threads up in exchange it
up no you're not up in exchange you have
one pawn but blacks attack is gone and
look at this pawn by the way look at
these pawns they're just so strong the
knight is amazing so despite the fact
your King is a little breezy you
actually are good here but again this is
stuff which computer can tell you a
human being to actually calculate
certain game
there's no way the only way you can do
it is calculate as much as you can
follow some basic principles try to get
your king safe at least as much as
humanly possible but to try to see all
this is is very difficult but again I
just you know a lot of pretty tactics
yeah we're going to get to that I wasn't
going to not show you I'm a little bit
mean but come on
and yes knife takes then the queen is
allowed g3 which is a purple so creepy
seven it looks like a good move right
you're attacking the rook if the rook
moves the g8 you can play 97 defending
the bishop hitting the rope defending
this you're a hero but blacks on
something even more heroic and again one
of the truly inspired ideas in this game
which moves you have montt very nice
there are times when okay there are
times when you have to be more
conservative you have to be like okay a
piece is attacked I got to move it and
then continue my attack but there are
times when one tempo matters more than a
rope or even than a queen obviously it's
not very common but in this attack one
temple means everything if you don't
attack with the right amount of time
you're going to end up just losing
you're going to end up getting your
pieces taken your attacks going to fail
rook g6 truly like an amazing move
you're basically saying you can take a
look not only take a look take a look
with check meaning you lose zero time
taking this rook but my attack is so
strong Queen h1 is such a difficult
threat you're just going to lose however
even took actually found an amazing way
to defend against this threat I was
going to ask people who didn't know but
nice job how did he do that
someone other than someone who knows I
knew that was the danger in showing this
game but it's one of my favorite games
so I was like alright I'm going to show
it hmm so nice see seven looks like a
nice move threatening mate right
defending your bishop however defending
your bishop does not defend against the
beautiful matron so I give checkmate
first now you now you can try playing
Queen g8 and giving checkmate in
response but your computer won't let you
do it yeah there's no there's no to
checkmate in a row yeah so if Knight
takes c3 I simply take with the night
and take at ya in this move I liked
actually instead of taking the bishop
with check or doing anything like that
you take here with which purpose yeah so
the King can't escape you're like no
King you're not running anywhere I kind
of like this Knight 64 moves very
sadistic but anyways it's not only win
but it's my favorite queen g8 easy to
miss a move like this no but keep in
mind you can't miss move like this the
main reason is that you're you've given
away almost your whole army your which
yeah it's alright but yeah I mean Queen
J it's not made but the whole idea is
that White's up so much material the
game is not over just because they lose
their Queen think about it in this
position before you play Queen g8 how
much material is white up a rook and two
pieces you could give up a whole Queen
and still be up material think about
this orokin two pieces is worth more
than a queen which means you can go off
a whole queen and still be up that's why
it's so dangerous to sack all your
pieces not just because if you don't
make you lose but because your opponent
give back so much to hinder your attack
so you can't miss things like this but
of course your soup up saw this and his
idea was that he can still attack even
without his rook so this happened
so what's material here two rooks for a
bishop and what's the pawn count here
blacks up upon so black has a queen and
pawn for two rooks and a bishop who's up
white by a little bit however blacks
whites still getting attacked and that's
what makes this difficult by the way
it's important that now the knight can't
stay here
because it's going to create extra
threats so why take the bishop and what
is black do so again it's important you
don't automatically capture pieces if
you take this night you give white
another move to maybe get out of some
threats meaning that maybe they activate
their rook maybe they play so he played
here actually which is quite a move not
not the first move you'd expect right
but his idea is that if you play here
King g1 you actually have no way to
checkmate because you can't really
threaten this bishop sorry annoying
you can draw but he still dead no
intention of drawing well you're no even
chip I mean you're no allow you suppose
so after King g7 the problem is that
maybe this move will be annoying the
idea being that if you try to check
bring me now I might have an escape
route it looks kind of sad I agree but
you don't want to give your opponent to
a chance to escape his idea was even
though I could take this Knight back I
still want to be attacking he only has
two pieces you're thinking what kind of
lunatic attacks with two pieces well the
kind of lunatic is dealing with this
King also your pawns are so good here I
would say your pawns count as attacking
pieces so Knight F 2 is quite a move and
what's the threat of Knight f2 by the
way the rook is the least of the worries
if you take the rook and white takes
back you're still down material right
and your attacks gone almost your main
idea is to play either Knight h3
threatening this mate and it takes then
mate or to play 94 the idea being if
takes you made on f2 so just to show you
so a Brooke a b1 for example tonight h3
that each one is actually not so bad but
this is a very simple checkmate right
because you can just take here this move
is a bit better and here this is
actually a better choice the main reason
being that I'm going to try to run if
you don't do this and now trying to run
doesn't do me much good because you
could say no no no and now queen up two
is inevitable so he played Bishop day
except for the only move available we
take that for but even though whites
fill up material blacks still attacking
so you played 96 rook DB one was kind of
interesting and how would you guys play
here well you take the knight you give
me a chance to maybe give a check right
really well first of all I can't check
you here so you don't have to run that
much but I just don't see like if I blew
my queen king say I go here but I still
don't see your checkmate if you go in at
age three I'll play King here if you go
Knight here I sit and maybe I'll play
rook up one on you I don't know okay I
mean maybe this is possible but I'm
still not sure you're going to give
checkmate here right
not so easy so I would say that right so
I would say also keep in mind that this
night is not that significant right
this Knight actually blocks a rook check
so it's not even such a big deal you
just have to continue to make threats so
net h3 check Queen h4 check is the key
move the idea being that now if you go
back there's mate and if King d1
notice how you're not taking anything
you're just grabbing pawns everywhere
that me all hope for him of getting a
piece back yeah and keep in mind these
rooks are not exactly prized possessions
here so III - oh yeah it can't move
forward and that's very true this pawn
is not going to be very significant so
you played 96 which makes more sense he
goes back to h2 saying whatever I'm
going to play Knight h3 next anyway
ahaha I don't know if you actually
laughed like that during the game but so
he plays rook db1 and now so h5 giving
your king in escape square however you
also give your opponent a checking
square sure but I'm not so sure you
actually wanted to do this now I have
Knight f3 for example I have 94 and some
positions not here obviously but I can
play Knight f3 well you want to keep the
pawn here just to stop 95 check but the
question is how do you get out of
Perpetual it's actually not so difficult
by the way
someone's paying attention yes the Queen
long-distance Queen moves guys covers b8
there's no perpetual which means why are
you trying to be fancy with threaten
meetin one rook check so takes the night
what else and now how this is b2 that
doesn't threaten me you can go to h2 but
I think h2 is actually a big mistake
because now I go back to g2 and I don't
see how you're going to checkmate if you
try to go to h4 here I play here and I
think the best you can hope for is a
draw now because again I just have way
too much material so you got to put the
king in a box right away yes see how the
King has no squares now and there's no
way to block it so Queen up 2 is going
to happen next move so you see the idea
that Queen f2 is coming no matter what
there's no checks so it's just resigned
and that's key this the reason why now
in this position obviously y could play
another move and last a few extra moves
but really if the Queen comes back
you're going to lose anyway the reason
why you took on h3 is because now black
only has one move to win and it's
important especially if you play such a
glorious attacking game that you don't
get careless for the last move and put
your Queen on h2 gang ahahaha I'm going
to win and then after Bishop g2 you have
no more way to give checkmate keep in
mind you only have a queen now there are
not that many ways you can give
checkmate with just one piece so you
need to make sure that you spot Queen g3
and be precise to the last moment so
again I mean it's such a messy game we
actually didn't even cover half of the
variations I looked at it's such a crazy
game but I like this game just because
ideas are really beautiful at least to
me but also because it teaches you lots
of things the long-distance Queen moves
definitely a theme in this game
keeping that in on d5 notice how many
more defensive
as you had just by checking with the raw
right knife if you check with the sea
Knight the knight on d5 is such a great
defensive piece and just so many ideas
that if you that when you're you know
taking tons of material on the defensive
side you have to always look for giving
that material back often giving lots of
it back as we saw in this case and also
just you know the different ways to
attack you have to discover exactly what
your mate thread is blacks attack would
have come to a grinding halt without the
rook threatening this Queen h1 Medich to
beautiful checkmate
without that checkmating idea not only
was it pretty it was necessary without
that idea there was no attack or at
least not a very effective one but most
of all it's just kind of a cool game and
I like going over it periodically so
it's very likely someone else will
choose this for a lecture but again I
could look at this game again and again
so I hope you guys enjoy the game
[Music]